just run
you he will be
I just want to say that it will date
rise is like easily one of my favorite
horror movies of the year
the first questions for Alyssa um you
are a thing of nightmares how did you
came to create this betrayal of Ellie
because she's frightening but there were
moments where I was like
kind of feel bad for her oh that's good
that's the first time I've heard that it
was so much fun
um creating her and the deadite version
of Ellie I um did a lot of work on
deadite movement and I had
a playlist that I put together and I
would sort of move around my hotel room
and and sort of created this deadite
movement and a muscle memory for that so
that it would click in for me on set and
it was like being in Flow State
um to have like the dead eye movement
and the little twitches and everything
that was the basis of the character and
from that it was just like sort of
feeling free and comfortable to try
whatever I wanted to try what kind of
songs do you have on this playlist like
what's the vibe it's very angsty stuff
like there's a lot of Massive Attack on
there and the band is called pusifer and
the song is Rev 22 20 or something but
it's like a different version of that
song not the original version and it's
really hard to find now Lily I really
feel for Beth like a dead possessed
sister was not what she signed up for
and on top of that she had to babysit
so much torture
ridiculous and like potentially if you
take responsibility for instance you
signed up for
not
sure this would be my version of
motherhood God damn it but yeah I mean
Beth was so fun to play there's a
journey there that even though it's you
know fight or flight fear Zone it's like
by the end she becomes full animal full
Primal mirroring her sister in a way
that like all of us have it in a demon
inside us you know
the demon of light though the demon of
protection
yeah motherhood is pretty Primal though
like when you think of it like the
stories I've heard from my friends it's
only trial by fire isn't it it's rusted
into it
no
now both Beth and Ellie really go
through a lot physically like were there
some stunts that you wanted to do but
Lee was like not relieving that to the
double yes the crawling on the wall I
really wanted to try and I could have
but it's too time consuming probably the
only one that I didn't get at all a
piece of yeah I and I that was the one
that I really wanted to do and it was so
fun because I'm sitting there and it's
like actually happening which was there
was this level of like even the crew
everyone was like oh totally just
popcorn moment while watching the like
live like monitor which is really fun
it's behind you
the crew reacting in real time to what's
going on in a way that doesn't happen
like a period piece well I hope you get
to try that the next time hopefully yeah
but that's all I have with you today
thank you so much thank you so much as
well have a beautiful day you too
mom Mommy's with the maggots there
foreign